dans un petit village de 600 quelques
personnes tout étonne plus calme on
trouvait ça j'ai pas tellement sous main
pour l'ex aucun risque je n'en fais plus
avec sol non chers malawite ma vie non
non on voit la chasse aux gros merisier
aux gros boulot zombies on va aller voir
ce qui aurait des candidats pour
débutants c'est tout défend d'érable qui
donnerait environ 200 ans qui sont
restés intacts pic
c'est de toute beauté
[Musique]
ça peut paraître un peu quand des fois
on vaut quasiment équitable dans les
arbres
[Musique]
non seulement la région les gens font ça
qu'ils m'ont henry mais bon en bateleur
battant et puis mon frère il me voir en
bois de paul
[Musique]
et
dakhla pour cinq ans de boîte price à
chaud même temps une maison pour un
univers fait 4 5 tab à 4 pour comprendre
que la mini boon fortune les arbres de
gens à partager entre les deux sens à
tous c'est pas terrible
tu prends la peine de faire une guitare
estienne
[Musique]
pour nous c'est un ami deuxième vie à
quatre jeunes avaient déjà parce qu'il
apparaît en fait ma après se sont dit à
m c'est quand même une belle grosse
maille aps un deuxième temps on vous qui
êtes encore en pleine forme
on va le sculpter
en attendant les vrais décors tout le
tour l'homme aux rythmes et sons à
l'aide d'une petite faction la chaîne
hbo continue à circuler puis imposé avec
trois points surtout danser diamètre
qu'est-ce que je me vois là c'est le
motif que le que le gréa du bois juste
validé si étonné parce que ça va être
motif comme ça d'engrais qui va faire
comme dédé des vagues
qu'est ce que je peux prétendre c'est
que je garde toujours un oeil ouvert
parce que ce soit à des trouvailles dans
le mot chauffage jonglant montra maison
n'a été dit bouleau jaune que j'ai fait
qui m'aide dans mon voisin c'est le plus
beau que j'ai eu dans ma vie qui doutent
déjà la bêta taille et de juillet vous à
brûler votre tour votre pas de trace de
noir c'est des fois ça va c'est un
livret qui auraient des grosses pattes
noires comme de calcul pourriture il ya
des fortes chances que ça devienne la
prochaine arbres à lutry ma guitare
[Musique]
à paris avec un instrument que tu vas
faire un salon tu présentes militaire
avec moi qui viens t'en parler et qui
est que le bois est formidable qu'il n'y
a rien à envier à personne
maintenant j'espère qu'après l'avoir
transformé en film et le transforme en
héritage je pense à un plus justice
alors pitié ne veut pas le boulot j'en
suis la bambine du québec en plus
les nie pas ces normes pour que ça
vaille la peine qu'on suis un peu les
bras
conçu par uniterre ya moyen de
transformer en ressources s'assoyait
public la tête pour les industries c'est
juste à nos deux oreilles qui a été
cassé par un doublon situent tous les
jours il décède en une journée de voir
le monde faire un match va trouver des
solutions
[Musique]
et
ans